I think like in the 90s women couldn't
even vote this is in the 90s the 90s so
yeah it was like 1918. no that's not
women got the right to vote no it was
1918.
18. oh 18.
okay
so remember but why why didn't women
have the right to vote women so
historically men had to go to war and
fight that is why women couldn't vote
was because we if you had the choice
today in 2022 when we were in war and
you had to go fight on the front lines
would you pick it personally this is
where people take me out of contacts and
say I don't think women should vote
personally if I in 2022 had the choice
where I had to go fight in the front
lines just like the men in a war or I
could give up my right to vote I would
give up my right to vote and that's what
happened back then is they equated
voting with going to war because